It is important to learn the
history of the United States
because you can learn new
things about what happened then,
and how it is now, and how
you can change the world.
We learn about history
so we don't repeat mistakes
that people made in history.
Sometimes history
have a lesson.
Abraham Lincoln saved
the enslaved people.
Yes, I think it's important
to know about slavery
so that nothing like that
will ever happen again.
It's illegal now, and it
wasn't for part of Abraham
Lincoln's presidency.
And he decided, no, we
can't do this anymore.
They weren't treated equally.
You would have to get
bossed around in chains.
I don't think anyone should
ever be forced to do something
they don't want to do.
People shouldn't be judged
off the color of their skin.
Whatever color they
are, that doesn't matter.
It just counts
what's on the inside.
Some people are
definitely treated
differently sometimes because
of the color of their skin.
There was like, some riots
that happened recently.
We just want like, happiness,
peacefulness, and no racism.
Well, a statue is
to show thankfulness.
I think for
remembrance and honor.
I think the person that
would deserve a statue
is Abraham Lincoln.
I think Obama.
John Cena.
Because he's the
most lit person,
and he can fight really good.
Emma Watson.
She stands up for
women's rights,
and I think that's very
good and important.
I think people who have
made big changes to the world.
If someone's changes
last, so should they.
Like Albert Einstein.
Martin Luther King.
He fought for civil
rights and for all of us
to be treated the same
way, not different.
America Inside Out
with Katie Couric,
only on National Geographic.
[laughter]
That's a tongue twister.